yeah that's very inside worthless why
are there so many backpacks I'm like
well if I had like self you wouldn't
have as much fun hey all right we're
here with Brian and our creative
director at insomniac on Marvel's
spider-man if you have not beaten the
game go do so it is well worth your time
we're gonna get heavily into spoilers
some point during this chat let's get
into it
[Music]
so Brian the games out people really
like it feel like to be finally done and
have it on the open it's a career
highlight for me I mean a hundred
percent I mean never in a million years
I ever think I'd be working on
spider-man Go game with him being
working on at insomniac and being the
creative director so it's been it's been
it's been an awesome weekend it was the
game came out on Friday my wedding
anniversary was on Saturday the reviews
were good I could reel finally relax for
like once in my life
well happy Anniversary thank you you
were talking about insomnia I it's
interesting to see how much of sin Sami
X DNA is in spider-man the obvious
comparison is sunset overdrive with
movement stuff but yeah unlike you get
the retching Clank minigames the gadgets
the overall tone yeah it I would never
have liked before I heard that insomniac
is doing a spider-man game I never would
have thought oh yeah I could see based
on their history thumbnailing that tone
but you did like could you talk about
how yeah that DNA kind of makes its way
into spider-man it's funny [ __ ] cuz I
probably one of the things I'm probably
most proud of that it feels like a
spider-man game made by insomniac I
think it's you know one of the reasons
why Marvel want to work with us was hey
we want Ensign that to put their their
spin on it and I think that you see it a
lot of places like sunset overdrive the
traversal gave us a kind of leg up I
mean obviously sunset was much more like
grinding and stuff but we kind of knew
what its gonna take to make a world
that's enjoyable open world we had you
know sunset was our first open-world
game but then we had to make something
that was several times larger and was
definitely much more photo real and the
character moves like three times as fast
as the sunset character so we had all
these dreaming things gonna figure out
but again we had experience doing it and
then like he said the like the the stuff
he does in the in the lab very much
Ratchet and Clank of minigames but then
like you look at the gadgets in the wet
and the gadget wheel that's classic
insomniac and then the suit powers like
we're just talking about the earlier
we're talking about the spider punk
guitar riff like that straight out and
saw Mack and being able to like just
generate all those like I remember
we were brainstorming all those
superpowers I even went to Ted who is
our president CEO and I said this is
like classic insomniac like just us like
singing a room brainstorming crazy ideas
and what I will tell you I was worried
Marvel's gonna say no these are not
gonna they're gonna fly it was really
one of the only things on the on the
game that was Ward Marvel might say no
to and they were like nope don't want
more of it who want more this kind of
stuff so oh yeah I mean I think the
insomniac DNA is you know very much
present in this game what did you
personally work on insomniac history so
I started back 10 10 years ago my first
game was resistance to okay I was
assuming a manager on that and then I
moved over to production after that and
worked
help finish up Ratchet and Clank and
crack in time then I moved over to over
strike fuse worked on that and then I
was lead producer on sense it overdrive
and then became crave director and
spider-man so like obviously we made a
lot more games than that but you know
just happen to be you know where we were
positioned that's the rules of games
like mainly worked on sure how does it
feel to be on top of a project as big as
this I don't I don't concern myself on
top of it I can sort of a part of it I'm
I mean yeah it's it's pretty off it's
pretty awesome
he's pretty crazy I never I mean like I
said never thought in a million years I
would doing something like this and to
work with character that's been so
important to me my whole life and so
many and I feel like you know least the
reception's been really positive so far
it's man this is this is great like I I
definitely choked up a couple times over
the weekend just kind of thinking about
it and just thinking about like what
like this is a long journey you know
these you guys interview a lot of people
you know how hard these things were to
make and it's like a lot of failures and
then finally have successes in terms of
it finally all coming together
so yeah it's yeah it's crazy yeah sorry
it's funny I feel like I've been so good
for so long talking about the game and
now that the game is out I'm actually
kind of like I
like an idiot half the time because I
just am so overwhelmed by like
everything like I'm like guys saying
like all weekend long I thought as me
catch up on sleep but I've been up to
like 2:00 3:00 in the morning
like looking at Twitter and photo mode
pictures like and like everybody from
everybody is tweeting them out and then
like our co-workers like finding them or
retweeting them and we're all liking
them and like I happen to mention on
Saturday to somebody like on Twitter I'm
like hey if you got a cool picture send
it to me and I feel bad if they send me
something I don't reply so like I'm up
like I kind of like it I gotta like it
and it's been now it's been awesome it's
been I never I knew the game was gonna
be talked about cuz it's spider-man I
knew that you know people would be
interested in I didn't expect this like
I did not expect it to be like the
business like like I feel like one
I got won't put like on I think it was
like Friday night or like Saturday it
was like my whole fee was a Spider Man I
was like oh just red and blue yes it was
it was surreal and like some of the
pictures that people are taking like I'm
safe house gave me meanwhile I'm
swinging by like the the Guggenheim and
taking the photo for the collectible and
it's just the front door stuff like and
which crazy is that you know you made
something special when you're the team
has just finished the game they're all
recovering and they're all home playing
the game and using photo mode and
posting their favorite pictures so like
animators artists designers they're all
up
they're all up late at night still
playing the game and posting pictures
it's been that's one thing for me it's
actually been really really surreal you
talk about all the sort of sharing and
stuff like I didn't come to this game as
a fan of spider-man and I've seen a lot
of the movies I've tried reading comics
in the past yeah this is the first
spider-man thing that has actually made
me like feel really endeared to the
character and and what he's doing and
who he is in New York like were there
any people on the dev team that kind of
became fans as well throughout the
creative process ah I mean I mean
fortunately we had a lot of Marvel in
spite of my fans on on staff already but
what you said is like one of the base
complements you can say because like
we want to make this game for spider-man
fans obviously a Marvel fan that comic
book fans but like we didn't want to
alienate anybody or we wanted to bring
in more people I you know if you've ever
heard if you've heard me talk before I
talk a lot about the Marvel movies I
love I love them like I'm a huge fan I
think the magic of those movies is that
you don't have to be a super big comic
book fan to enjoy them because I think
what they do the magic of the Marvel's
least in my my opinion is that yes
you're gonna get all the great superhero
fantasy and stuff that you want you're
gonna get good you know the awesome
outfits the big fights the epicness of
it but you strip all that away they're
human stories they're really good like
furro furro for as long as game has been
development I've said guards the
Alexei's my favorite Marvel movie and I
switch to black panther just like in the
last six weeks I've been a lot of planes
watching a lot of black panther affinity
or a lot but I think Black Panther in my
opinion such a such a great movie
because if you strip away all the great
tech and all the you know all his suit
and everything it's really a coming
issue worried about how that person's
learning to be king and how the villain
really shows T'Challa how to be how to
be king like you know he starts the
movie was saying I want to be just like
my dad and - no no I'm gonna makan is
gonna be changed and I'm gonna be a
different King and we're gonna we're
gonna expose what kind you know Ana's
gonna welcome the world and we're gonna
welcome it
that's a great story if if you didn't
have any of the cool superhero stuff so
I think that's what we try to do we
really try to tell a great super like
you know when you're here making a
spider-man game you're like well of
course it's got to have awesome swinging
awesome fighting great villains cool
cool tech we want to give you a full
fantasy but strip it away we want you to
have a great you know great story as
well that it's just good about you know
it's a coming age story for Pete about
him becoming young adult yeah I was
gonna say I think if you were to play
through just straight through the main
story without going for any collectibles
etc you might I don't know what that
like percentage would be but you spend a
good deal of time like not being in the
Spidey suit you know you got Mary Jane
yeah we put a spoiler warning the
beginning like you've also got Miles
Morales yeah got a few different
playable characters what was it like
coming into that and like how did you
approach those sections like what was it
like not having the superpowers to lean
on and like the crazy insomniac gameplay
and just relying on the writing and like
the walking and talking et cetera
it was that's really hard I mean there's
a really actual really hard we hadn't
done a lot of that stuff I didn't omni
AK oh yeah we haven't done a lot of that
stuff I think that you do you know you
lean a lot on the you know lean on your
writers but like for example that miles
Mac is a spoiler Kentucky possible yeah
so then why the miles mission like at
City Hall that really came together
because the designer just really got
into the narrative and got into the
experience and said here's how I would
hurt how I would make this feel
emotional for him and then it was the
lighters the environment people we
really we really invested a lot of time
and effort into those scenes and you
know even though it's a known idea
spider-man we had never made a
spider-man game so for us it was a new
IP it was like making a new IP so we had
a lot of challenges and we knew the
first thing was get spider-man right but
then I'm like well I really would like
to see Peter playable and they're like
okay that makes sense
that'll be a challenge okay I'm like
yeah I also would like to see MJ cool
because I really want her to have her
arc to play up more than just the
cutscenes and they're like okay well
that's gonna be hard but okay and then I
was like yeah and I've now elevated Maz
Morales and I want him to be a playable
character and we want to see it and we
threw a through a lot at the dev team
and they
thank God took it out and embraced it
and what I really wanted to do was we
want to do was to show a superhero world
from all different angles really show
what is it like you know obviously we're
happy he's a superhero it has great
abilities but what is it like to be in
that world and not have superpowers just
a different perspective of the world and
I thought that would be something
interesting
not to mention is if you have the player
actually if you have that character
actually playable you can have much more
of a fulfilling character arc for that
character like I think MJ MJ's arc is so
much better because she's actually
playable at certain points I think miles
is a better character because he's play
a lot of parts you kind of you're you
walk you walk a mile in their shoes
right you could got to get a little bit
more better understanding about what
they're going through how they're
changing one of these scenes my favorite
when you play as Peter Parker is
actually when he's dressed as spider-man
but not able to use his powers at the
Halloween party yeah that seemed it just
from the outside looking in and my
assumptions that the dev team probably
had a lot of fun making lots of fun cuz
there's so much happening yeah kudos to
you guys cuz it all felt like it was
happening without me being there you
know someone we like grew up on
spider-man but hasn't like been into him
in a while I saw so many like villains
that I forgot about or at least like
old-school styles of like shocker it
said okay so interesting that was one of
the earlier missions we actually made
like it was actually one of those
earlier missions main development and
originally you were going to interact
with a Mysterio looking character okay
the vulture and Rhino that was a that
was a three and then what happened is
our lead character artist Gavin he was
like we should just do more I was like
all right man go can you can make a
funny-looking scorpion outfit he's like
I got this and they they added the
electro they added the scorpion that
came in like within the like the last
three months of development like and
actually gavin worked with the designer
neil to like move everything around so
like most likely you would like you
could kind of go where you wanted but
they you know cleverly like kind of
created a path were like a lot of time
you would actually end up if you just
kind of be lined the stuff like the
mission you would see a lot of those
characters around and you know so debt
and that's example of like
I didn't ask for those extra things I
didn't ask for them to redo the crowd I
didn't ask them to read we shuffle
things they just want to make the game
better and like I can give you like a
thousand examples of how that's happened
across the game like just the team
really that's one of the things up he
said and something make me feel like an
insomniac game that's a classic example
of that so funny and you were talking
about being on Twitter this week and I
was doing the same thing while I was
finishing up the game and I kept seeing
like people like showing off like here
in another episode of insanely polished
Triple A games Peter's voice actor I
think is named URI which is your knee
because he talks to URI the whole game
so so uh yeah sorry no so we cast URI
low and follow spider-man we cast Tara
Platt who's Azure wanna be URI and Tara
are married so man I know they're Mary
Mary
so URI is playing the game I think a
Saturday night and I sent him so what
does it feel like when URI is playing
he's hearing URI talk to your and I
cleared my mind explosion yeah I send
this picture like chocolate probably
going and it was like that kind of thing
I was like I really kind of nuts and I'm
sure that maybe would make a great gift
but I just did in my face great John
Travolta yeah yeah so I think that it's
just that yeah I mean that was just it
was a crazy and he's great and he is
awesome and sorry I never told you know
I think my talking about face off threw
me off yeah
no I didn't URI was awesome in that game
which I didn't expect so like I said I
grew up on spider-man and I was playing
this game because I I grew up with like
I've been playing insomnia games my
whole life yeah but I did not expect to
get super in the story but I was just
saying like when I beat the game last
night oh my god so much happens like
yeah a lot like obviously I do want to
get into like the future of this
potential series because you clearly I
mean in in typical Marvel fashion
there's a post-credits scene but also
before that a lot happens but like
obviously bringing miles up and like did
you know from the beginning like you
said you wanted Rick miles into it did
you know you wanted to mine the more
modern spider-man comics and bring in
someone like the only other person that
Don's that suit yes so I mean I the two
the two biggest influence obviously were
I mean you know the biggest influence
was the comics we looked at looked at
you know and I think just the and then
obviously you know I've said I'm a big
fan of movies and kind of them bringing
more people into these worlds so
originally miles was not gonna be as big
of a part of the game at all like he was
originally just a tease in the first
trailer he was like on his phone with
Luhrmann's literally was like we start
developing the first story he really
wasn't there to like like polish credit
see like I think the original plan was
and I how many of the first thing the
first problem telling this he was like
he was going to be watching like the
events of the of the of what happened in
the game like on his computer and like
someone says and miles or something like
that I mean I don't something like
something like that I don't even know
but then I had I had read the miles
comics you know over the years but I
just I kind of like I just went up at
least read it
let me read him again and I started
getting more and more into him and I
said is there any way we could put him
more in there and we talked a lot about
making this a very unique spiral
universe something like the familiar at
the fresh familiar but still have it mix
things up and I went to Bill Roseman our
executive creative director at Marvel
and I was like bill what if we what if
we had miles in the world but it wasn't
some like like dimensional portal he
comes through they just he just lives
and lives there you know he's 15 years
old he grew up it was like he was a huge
spider-man fan and Bill's like go for it
and that's how it really came to be well
you also get to know his dad first and
then yeah it's a pretty tragic way how
did you get to meet my lore how Peter
meets glass yeah it's a pretty emotional
it's a pretty emotional scene that's
actually one of some of the first
cinematics we actually shot was so Nagi
Jeter who plays miles that was one of
his test scenes the one worth the
funeral that was actually one of his
test scenes actually his testings were
the funeral and then the tease at the
very area okay was where his to like the
dorm room yeah like yeah like those are
the two those are the two moments that
we actually have to put them through and
obviously the scripts changed and
evolved over time but uh and we knew
like yeah that's our miles just like we
knew that was our area
yeah even like with the writing itself
like a wooden Jefferson first got
introduced I was like oh so he for the
rest of the game he's gonna be that like
the Robin like like talking to ride to
the cop on the inside that's like
helping Superman to all sudden very
sorry Batman all of a sudden you kill
them off and then you know you're you
find out that Miles Morales is a son if
you're a fan of the comics that's got an
added layer yeah we put a lot we we try
to I mean like yet for example like if
you don't know the comics you're like oh
that's a sad story of you know someone
who came a hero men tragically dies we
feel like oh that's miles dad and and
normally it's Rio in the comics who
passes away so like kind of trying to
mix things up because I thought we
thought that you know the kind of the
mentorship the partnership the
friendship the wanted Pete miles to have
it would have worked better if you know
sorry JD died you were just talking
about working with with Marvel and
that's it's interesting to hear because
I mean like talking with other people
who worked with licensed properties like
last year we spoke to monolith and like
they're like dealing with a Tolkien
property it sounds like Marvel is pretty
painless which is maybe yeah be
surprising is not the right word but
just because of how big they are it
seems I think that it's I would on tour
obviously you know if we go the game's
finishing up we do a lot of preview
tours and stuff and I think number one
question I got asked was what's it like
working Marvel and truth is it's it was
great like they you know luckily the
Marvel Games team is 15 minutes from her
office so like if we had like any type
of like thought something's not gelling
they would just come over and by the
afternoon it was solved but I think the
truth is we we were on we were on the
same page for the most part the very
beginning the project I think they knew
that we respected the franchise really
really well and didn't want to screw it
up i they really embraced us one and to
mix things up like Bill Mike and Eric
all those guys they were really yeah
let's let's let's try some things and
like you know even the end of the game
was you know I thought was going to be
super you know like oh god I think I'll
let this happen and they were like sure
like so I'm I'm really really close with
those guys like really really close like
I said they're my friends like I can
send the honorary insomniacs like they
don't like I don't have them wear badges
around
on the office they're just bill Mike and
Eric hanging out like all right what up
they'll get your whatever you gonna
drink let's talk for a couple hours um
you know it's it's a very great
lationship and I mean I can tell you
they've made us better developers but
our storytellers and all that stuff I
said can be the same thing we said about
Sony like we have just as great support
you know I I was fortunate enough to
work with mark Cerny on this project
he's face was a mentor for me on this
project
Grady hunt Connie booth are our
producers just ultimate support so as
much as all the stuff I said about
Marvel I can say the same thing about
Sony I'm really curious about marks
Ernie's involvement because I wasn't
totally aware of that like how he was he
in the ongoing development Barry yeah
yeah meet with them I mean we met with
them every week you know sometimes you
be traveling every month but anytime I
had a question I would ask mark for
guidance and yeah I mean as you know
mark is one of the race really really
smart and it was making him for a long
time and knows it's seen a lot of the a
lot of the issues that come up and he
just he's really great insight whether
it's something really to tackle it's
when they really didn't story design and
you know he was just he's great he's a
great person to work with so I'm super
fortunate to have work with someone like
Mark you guys did he because any
advantage when it came to working with
the PlayStation architecture I know it's
not terribly foreign and that it's based
on PC stuff probably a better question
for the tech guys but like we had
already we were we were already making
Ratchet and Clank for ps4 so we kind of
already had we kind of had a leg up so
he just took all that all that time you
know and just applied it to spider-man
obviously they look different you know
one's the Lombax running around or
another spider-man but um but yeah I
mean we we're lucky we have what we have
we ever make our own engine we have our
own tech team so you know and I think a
really the game works so well from a
technical standpoint because it's it's a
engine that we've been working for a few
years now our tech team really
understands that our dev team
understands that really well what it can
do and really push it really hard and I
think that
you know I didn't and don't quote me on
this but I'm sure there were some
hurdles that I probably people who want
to tell me because I would probably
freak out about it but yeah I mean it's
it's you know everybody's like so look
is it running well as on regular ps4 as
a pro-am like it runs really well man
like I have for a long time I only
played on the rail ER ps4 so I'm really
proud from a technical standpoint what
the game is able to achieve so those
timelines actually no I think of it
overlapped pretty heavily ps4 retching
Clank was like was that simultaneous or
was did you stop retching like before
some of it was simultaneous this was
your first now they think of it I didn't
work on ratchet right yeah
this was the insomniacs as a company's
first new IP on ps4 isn't because once
that overdrive was the first thing yeah
so sunset was Xbox one and then Ratchet
and Clank was time with the movie
release came out and then Spiderman
that's weird to think that like it's
funny to look at insomniac and see like
oh they did start out for this but then
of course ratchet and resistance were
such like Sony exclusives yeah but
technically it's an independent company
yeah and then they like based on numbers
that I saw last night's the
fastest-selling Sony exclusive over God
of War right now that was pretty cool
yeah that was pretty cool to see I've
seen like you and Cory bar log tweeting
each other and say yeah I love Cory he's
he's the man he's ah he's awesome I look
up at him a lot
i as a creative director and someone who
is just all-around great guy like I'm
I'm also a huge war fan like a gigantic
got a war fan like I actually been
saving god of war till we shipped like I
from January to September I have outside
of 45 minutes for God of War I played
nothing but sweating because I felt like
I was cheating if I played anything else
l or I felt like just guilty I'm like
I've got I gotta gotta read this mission
I got to play this thing so I like I
didn't I couldn't even play it till
after the breeze came out I'm like the
breeze will come out and then I'll start
or maybe I start playing right before I
don't know I need yeah they start
playing dead works I need a distraction
well I was driving my wife literally
insane and she's like mom she start
playing God worn out like okay so I
start playing that shut up spider-man oh
there's no what happened in the world of
my wife but yeah and that game is just I
guess
I came as so damn good I came as so good
and but I I have to say what was really
cool on Friday one of the best moments
was to see all the first party studios
like tweeting congratulations or like
seeing Sony Santa Monica like make the
the artwork of Spidey hanging upside
down shown at Reyes the phone and then
the horizon zero dawn guys they had all
of them together and then I mean
gorillas had that and then we had I
think it was a Sony Ben did something as
well as Naughty Dog and then
sucker-punch took a group photo of
everybody doing stuff if this feel like
a big family it really does and like I
happen to like talk to Cory probably
more than any of any point in terms of
the first party crave director I talk to
him more than anybody I know I'm the
best for myself but yeah he's I mean
yeah he's I guess that he's a man it's
funny all the games you just mentioned
especially God of War but then last year
horizon zero dawn and then he be out
Stoney bun with days gone coming up yeah
that last was too gay and that's gonna
be brushed to is coming up and there
goes the Tsushima as they're showing us
oh my god it's like the first party
lineup is yeah but it's also like those
were all work sick a lot no it's alright
I'm sick those are all it's funny to see
those are all single-player games
yeah this is only single-player for dead
right so I was talking about that last
week actually I was talking to Cory
briefly about it and obviously is making
god of war and then like gorilla making
horizon like after visceral shutdown and
Call of Duty announced that what can
have a campaign there was this like I
think a lot of people most people were
like no that's false look at all these
Studios tails and triple-a Studios focus
on single player but what are your
thoughts on like that notion like
however inconceivable it is that single
player is somewhat dying with these
studios like Bioware shifting from
traditional RPGs to anthem
what is your what are you thoughts in
the state of single-player development
because I think it was Amy Hennig
actually with mark Cerny at a chat
two years ago or last year after
visceral shut down and she was saying
she wasn't saying single players dying I
think that's what people took out of it
but she was saying like that model of
just a single player game working for
five years on it like God of War it's
not viable it's not viable it's not like
sustainable like what are your thoughts
on that I think that
I think people for some reason want to
say it has to be either or it doesn't
like we can have fortnight's and we can
have god of War's or we can have you
know you know we can you know pub G and
we can have spider-man or Last of Us to
like doesn't need to be a choice there's
that many people playing games today it
doesn't need to be either yes co player
games are hard to make they take a long
time it's true
can we get smarter better yeah sure but
I just think it in a day these these
things do take time so - so just things
like fortnight and pop G like you know
like you know they you know fortnight
was worked on for a long long time and
then they made right because the switch
was over no no I mean I could be wrong I
don't think I'm wrong but like that the
mode that everybody loves in for tonight
was not part of the original package
right so that think about that took how
many X years to get to that point right
they found their magic X amount of years
so I just think it's something where
these games are no matter what you make
whether a single-player MMO you know
online competitive mobile whatever it is
these things take a long time to make
there's a lot of aeration is a lot of
things that can go wrong because it's
not a passive medium you're literate
inter it's interactive there's a lot of
things that can just like I always say
like my philosophies like 90% of the end
of elm was really really hard but 10% is
the greatest C in the world and that 10%
is greater than that 90% and I think
single-player games are here to stay
same thing with all the you know all the
other types of games and I love my man I
love making store a story basting a
player game I think that I think you
know I can just lose myself in a
narrative it's one of the reasons why I
still love going to movies I go to
movies a ton for two hours I can just
shut everything off and forget about
what's going on in the world and just
enjoy great a great story and a great
world I feel like that's another thing
we do with games but it could be with
people it can be on your own
so my long win answer is single-player
games are not dead were there any
pitches internally about how to add
multiplayer to spider-man sure really
make sure not games service we weren't
going anywhere gonna do that sure yeah I
think what I think it in a day
there's always talks about you know
different types of modes or extending
the life of the game it's one of reasons
why we're making those DLC right now um
but you know we added and the day was we
wanted to create a story based
open-world spider-man game heavy uh
narrative really immerse you into the
worlds that Peter Parker and spider-man
fulfill the fantasy of being spider-man
but also tell you a very emotional
engaging human story and I feel like we
achieve that so even though there there
could have been discussions about other
things it took away from that number one
goal look we're not gonna do it what a
little touches I love that contributed
to that feeling you're describing is the
fast travel sequence breeze in the
subway yeah do you know that I'll tell
you how that came about a blessing that
came about for fat so we knew it's funny
yet you mentioned mark so mark was like
hey so what's our plans for fast travel
and I'm like I don't know we'll figure
it out yeah and because he was like
we're gonna need it and I'm like and
you're totally right we did even though
it's super fun to swim around the world
right at some point at some point some
people just gonna want to say hey I want
to get from point A to point B fast and
we talked about talked about just
someone came up with the idea of using
the subway and originally I think
they're just gonna be like a quick
animation but one of our designers Josue
go up the lot build the open-world like
from a design standpoint like one night
like worked with an animator Steve and
they put together like couple those
vignette those vignettes and he came
over me like he's like almost like a kid
who was like like I did something I hope
you're not mad and we all looked at it
and we're like this way this is genius
and you are a rockstar and you and Steve
are the bomb and and it's also so
insomniac it was like it was a great
night
it was something we need to do saw Mac
tuned Sonic's came together
collaboratively no one telling
they had to do this thing they got
excited a passion about idea it fit the
studio if it our DNA and that's came
together so yeah that's it's that's
really what happens well it's also
really like New York too which was nice
it's like no one pays attention right I
love that so much like actually you've
been talking about the open-world design
and that's funny because we were talking
when at first when we first started
playing it before I did like when we
before the reviews came out and we were
both talking about how like the open
world itself in terms of like it's
there's a lot of collectibles there's a
lot of like it's not the open world
that's revolutionary in terms of
fundamentals it's great yes it's amazing
and it allows you to move through it but
it's how you interact with the open
world that is look what makes the game
so yeah did you was there did you know a
certain point you just really wanted to
nail that foundation so being spider-man
would be fun or were you trying to like
do cool things with the open world ah
all the above kind of and I think for me
was when it really clicked was the
moment we started getting suits in the
game and let progression kind of guy in
the game and I remember spending a
weekend I was supposed to play all these
like we call it the main story missions
and all I did was go around and do all
the side content so I could get tokens
to go spend on suits yeah and I was like
oh well we got it like that was it was
it just has a very like kind of
addictive game loop that was kind of
that that's when I kind of knew you know
I definitely think going you know we
feel like you know we can we can do more
with the world and the interactivity
with it but you know I think you know we
we have we have a world that people like
to explore I mean obviously you see it's
many people already within like after
four days of it being out already
platinum in the game and really going
out and doing a lot of stuff whether
it's side quests or where's the resource
stations or the collectables
or you know just all the crazy stuff I'm
finding the secret the secret landmarks
we understand people like to explore in
New York City and we want to keep keep
doing that even our DLC going back to
Twitter and stuff and talking about
moving around there's so much I can't
imagine the amount of work that went
into making the swinging but like
perfect because it's very nearly if not
flawless its close because I mean I
can't wait
was watching and like there's the voice
acting from Yuri will like change from
exactly exist to resting yeah and then
also like someone was saying there might
be like a stretch on the web depending
on where you are on I don't know if
there's like yeah it's behind it yeah
there's a stretch and no much went into
that oh but well so we literally that
was literally the first thing we did we
had like this really ugly looking
spider-man swinging through this like
gray box in New York City and it like
you know it didn't have like any speed
lines or effects so like it kind of felt
slow but yeah we pretty much worked on
it from that day all the way till we
were adding new like swing animations
like less than a month before gold like
because now we got feedback of like I
want to see more animations and I went
over to Elliot are actually Elliot came
to me he's like hey I think I can have
like two more things before we Shepard
I'm like go for it man so we were
constantly the biggest the biggest
hurdle we had with it was we never
wanted to stop someone's flow and
momentum and you know like we didn't
want the pancake on the on the thing and
there's like stalker momentum it worked
a really a hard time a long time on just
getting that since a flow fluid be and
that's an addicts it's a style like one
thing I was really particular about and
I'm sure I drove people crazy was like
this game had that fire escapes like New
York City is littered with fire escapes
but they're like the worst things in the
world for traversal like yeah typically
they're just gonna kill you and those
guy and the guys figure out how to like
whether you're going up or through to
like have not getting your way and stuff
like that so and that's where kind of
the more that parkour element started
coming in and like when you're on the
ground you're on the rooftops so it was
a constantly it constantly evolving and
then we just did a lot of we did a
metric ton of play testing like I'm sure
Cory talk to you probably about him
doing a lot of play testing on god of
war just same thing just doing a lot of
doing a lot a lot of play testing
getting in people's hands and saying
just get from point A to point B does it
work or like you know some of the more
fine-tuned stuff of like try to make
sure you can hit that you know that that
concrete cylinder and go through it
things like that so and that's we had a
whole traversal team just dedicated like
all they did all project was that and
they nailed it it's it's awesome they're
very similar feeling to combat as well
though where I never felt like there was
ever a moment that Spiderman wouldn't do
something awesome with the environment
around him the other I knew he was gonna
do it or not it was like the way there
yeah I see you keep describing the game
to me it's like the feeling of not being
able to be hit it's like one of the best
things in this game
combat took a while because we hadn't
made that we haven't made a ton of melee
base before like really like a lot of
stuff was guns
you know like whether it's ratchet
resistance sunset we have a lot of
gunplay so we definitely had some work
but it was it was really toward the late
like I feel like we got it the beginning
very beginning of the of the of the
development was about nailing the tone
and the voice of the character and kind
of getting our story then it was about
traversal finally kind of came in and
then combat came in after that and it
really was that moment where we said
it's the idea of the acrobatic
improviser getting him off the ground
make you know how the all the flow and
fluidy that we have and its traversal
bringing out the combat and then we
adding things like the environment or
acts in the and the gadgets and the suit
power suit powders came online you know
later
it all kind of start crystallizing and
my favorite thing was I talked about you
know I'm on the weekends as you know I
put as you probably until I played the
game a lot on the weekends I would just
take the build home and I would just try
out all these things I didn't realize
they added these things like for example
I remember but you could punch up a guy
in the air and then if you like you can
grab them and slam them down right and I
just happen to think to myself like what
if I punch him up in the air and I try
to juggle them with my webs and then I
pull them down what would happen and
wouldn't you know I can do that and when
you yank him down since he has webs on
him he sticks to the ground like all
those little experiments or like what if
I what if I put a tripwire
so the tripwire is a gadget where if you
put it on a surface and a guy walked by
they'll get stuck to the building or if
there are two guys they'll stack
together I'm like well if I'm doing
stealth could I use it it can I put it I
always put it on the ground can i oh no
it was I was I had a guy running at me
and I was like well what if I started
placing it on him I place it so I know
he's looking he's beeline and right
toward me if I just stick the tripwire
right in the ground will he get sucked
down
and once you know boom they just thought
of that look all these things I just
like it was really really cool to see
the team like they just they really
started creating a definitely it has a
sandbox feel to it so I want to ask real
quick I feel like you got something to
say talk about sticking people to stuff
when you throw enemy off a building good
they get stuck out of the building like
was that a requirement because
spider-man can't kill anyone or did
someone think I've got a great idea
I know it wasn't a I would say it was
like a requirement we knew he was gonna
kill people so we're like how are we
gonna do it like we talked about like
having little web like parachutes
excited should be easier because I was
worried that people would just like go
down and start whaling on the guy and be
all buggy so we end up to come with the
idea of yeah basically took sends out
like a little mic shift makeshift
tripwire and he gets the people get
stuck to the building but what crazy was
for me was that do you remember the
first e3 where we showed real game like
we showed like the the gameplay of the
of the construction site and you would
one part was we kicked the guy off and
right before he he fought we grabbed him
slammed down and edit or I was doing
demos I was like doing like demos behind
closed doors and some guy some editor
asked me about writer asked me about it
and that became like a story and I was
like wow this is like really important
to people and I'm like thank God we
added that feature thank you yeah so
yeah it wasn't like it was a requirement
in a way it wasn't like it was something
we just knew like PI spider-man's not
gonna kill people so it just made sense
and we think we did in a pretty clever
way you talk about combat and like all
the different things that got added it's
funny this is such a minor observation I
feel like but between like combat and
maneuv like swing and traversal I feel
like you were running out of space on
the controller I always say that all the
time yeah no war button yeah like it was
we have no more button combined our dug
our traversal lead programmer who is was
instrumental making sure so great and
like he's taught me like so much about
development throughout the years he I
was he was a to me we're running out of
buttons we have more buttons yes ya know
it's funny because I was like I didn't
even know you could do the whole wrap
around corners with circle and so like
yesterday yeah oh yeah like a feel and
that's all because sometimes it does it
automatically if you get onto a building
wait enough in the wall run yeah but
then I found out you can do that so then
I was like it's funny because it's if
you
to just swing through the world you
could and then if when you unlock the
the roll and jump yeah so if you do have
any hit the ground you can just get
right back up I love the aiming for a
point and then when you time the X right
you just explode off it that's the best
thing I don't know like it is amazing
what that edge roller it pulls off in
that game and the tricks to like the
flipping and stuff is funny the the you
know the like the charge jump came
online super late the tricks came online
super late it's one of those things I'm
sure you guys talked a lot of L pers
when the game is finally there he now
you're like oh I can add all I can do
all these things a lot of that stuff
just comes in in like you know like our
lead producer Scott's probably like
Brian you're killing us killing us right
now but when when the team gets so
excited about something you want to
embrace it and that's you know a lot of
the things we do we just embrace the the
passion and they just create cool things
so yeah it's it's that's awesome Nino's
and I think the foster us when came
traversal was we wanted you to feel like
spider-man right away so sure look I
didn't want people like it's one reasons
why when you jump out the window it's
like get people traversing right away
that's the ultimate fantasy of being
spider-man but then as you said over
time you start to discover more things
that you can do and you feel much more
SAS you feel like a greater superhero
over time that's my marketing line but
then it's also I don't know like we
again we put a spoiler warning at the
beginning you're talking about how you
did a lot with the traversal with a
combat like a lot of it maybe was
unnecessary but in the end it yeah it
makes it better still guns finger guns
and all oh yeah you're all that stuff
just the guys thought it'd be cool to do
the subway yeah but then also like the
ending oh my god I beat last night and I
knew there was gonna be some stuff
coming out but like first of all the
push back the ending I love them again
there's so much that happened I'll
answer all your class you know I well
I'll say that I liked it now I would say
yeah I mean between the buff final boss
fight like there's so many different
like people like have there's so many
relationships established but also as
you know from beginning you wanted to
set up a sequel or like set up a
potential series or yeah what is that
like I don't know how much you could
talk about I can't talk plan
can't talk a lot about it but I think
that we we always want to think ahead a
little bit sure I think that the ending
was we worked on the ending a long time
whether it was the auto fight whether it
was decision to kill we just boil it
right kill okay and then setting up you
know miles with powers and then with
Norman and Harry what happens with them
yeah I mean it was all strategically
planned over the years and it's
something like we went back and forth a
lot on all those decisions especially
obviously the method like Mae was a huge
thing we test we wrestled with it for a
long time like I changed my mind
multiple times and then said this is you
know play the game kind of it had some
other people hadn't played the game as
much as me play it and feel like was it
earned because I didn't want I fear what
people gonna say you're just doing it to
get some shock value out of the
situation and when I had more people
telling me no I feel like it's an earned
it's earned and it really helps
crystallize Peters arc we went with it
and it's bold it's it's gonna you know
it's gonna change things but I think
that um you know it felt like it was the
right ending to the game I'm also really
proud of the the the auto fight in terms
of like how it really feels like there's
a narrative arc to it as much as there
is like you know game playing mechanics
to it so yeah I'm really super proud of
it yeah we're always thinking about you
know I can't really say more than what
we're talking about with the DLC but
yeah I'm always kind of thinking about
what could come become in the future
it's funny despite the fact that you
only see him in like a little Kodak pip
Harry Osborn's actually kind of a big
character and like based on what's going
on he's a big fulcrum for everything
going on yeah he is you know we you know
we we we've tried not to just put
somebody in the game just because it was
like well you know I expect him to see
we wanted even though you really never
see Harry til the end
if you do all the research stations
you'll start if you do all the research
stations and you really explore Norman's
apartment when your that MJ mission
you're really gonna understand what
what's going on with Harry and and that
was another example of a character
really want to change like I think for
so long people think of him as just the
you know the party boy the the
good-looking guy who's you know some way
and we wanted to change him up a little
bit
same thing with like we obviously did
with MJ I'm saying we did with Pete too
less lesser degree but we wanted just I
think like I said I've said this little
pot a lot a lot in the past like the
ultimate spider-man comics it's such a
good job of kind of mixing things up
with like still feel like a spider-man
game sparing my experience and that's
kind of the model we wanted to use just
give people enough twists where they may
not matter what's gonna happen next
there's so many pillars I feel like yet
a nail you had a nail making a betting
Sami at game making a spider-man game
making a good like open-world game
making it feel good like how do you even
juggle those all at the same time like
that's such a it's loaded question I
realize no it's it's it's it's a really
really hard it's really really hard I
used to have a lot more hair in my head
when I started this project um that's my
joke we say what's true and yeah I think
if you think about it from those stand
points you're gonna get overwhelmed and
you just take it day by day and the
truth is like that's you know I mention
a lot of its on X today they're the ones
that make you making not lose your mind
during it because you know like someone
like Doug is gonna do whatever it takes
to make this reversal better or you know
our lead animator Bobby's just gonna
kill himself to make sure that the
cinematics look in anime beautifully and
making it spending making sure that
Peters face looks great and every single
scene then you hand it off to the
lighters and then you're working with
the audio team like there's so many
people that you just are so talented
that that's what gives you the
confidence and then you have and then
you have your checks and balances you
have you know people like Ted playing
the game every day every week and giving
you feedback you have people like our
Sony producers playing the game and
giving us tons of feedback the Marvel
team same thing so like you know I
always make a joke when I present like
if I could get past Ted I felt
I think the same thing was because Ted
you know hey Ted's one of the best
presenters I've ever seen and I feel
like if he was happy with something I
was presenting we're gonna be okay I
think I felt the same way if we could if
we if the people we were working with
were satisfied with it and our team was
happy with it we're going to be okay and
so when I think about all those things
you mentioned I start to like get a
little freaky but yeah I mean I think
that's what gives me the confidence is
that the team making it and the people
that were working with giving us the
right kind of feedback cool done playing
for a while you're gonna focus on God
worn out no I'm gonna juggle between the
two I really want to I want to platinum
the game for sure I really want to play
God it's odd I will tell you it is
really weird playing the game without a
notebook like because I put our laptop
like whenever I play the game at home it
was notes and notes and notes and notes
or like Excel sheets or whatever and it
was really where I was actually just
texting our game director Ryan Smith
over the weekend I said dude it's weird
playing the game and not having a laptop
next to me like I just like and I'm like
in like bugs I knew existed both like
before I'm like okay me fixed it
like like oh oh they fix ok they fixed
that one oh all right that one's fixed
but I'm like expecting the bug to happen
and it doesn't because I'm just so used
to seeing it and you know it's a work in
progress for him but like yesterday I
did all the towers and I got I got all
the backpacks and yeah I'll definitely I
am looking for to got more though for
sure
cool well congratulations you made a
very good game thanks guys thanks for
having me it's so super fun
[Music]
you